there's something just so satisfying
about getting things done you know
checking the boxes off and your to-do
list walking the dog sending emails
doing your laundry you know it makes you
feel good inside it makes you feel like
you're not as lazy as you probably are
but if you're like me you often get
distracted easily and actually don't get
stuff done maybe some days you lack the
motivation to do stuff in general so you
have a paper due on Thursday it's
currently Monday there's no way you're
touching that paper till like late on
Wednesday or maybe to the last like
possible our last couple of hours on the
Thursday you get the idea that's not the
way things have to be I'm about to tell
you a secret that will make you more
productive perhaps even more productive
than you thought you ever worked and it
all starts with a checklist now I know
what you're thinking a checklist I make
checklists every single day it doesn't
really help I just make them makes me
feel good it makes me feel like I've
actually done the things on the
checklist but I never actually end up
taking all those boxes that's because
you're doing checklists wrong and I used
to do checklists wrong all the time
until I discovered this epic tip I mean
this looks like your average checklist
right but it's actually so so bad
because all of these tasks vary an
important effort concentration it causes
more trouble than not having a checklist
at all basically never make checklists
like this again so here's how to make an
effective checklist step 1
brain dump basically dump every
short-term task and goal onto a piece of
paper anything and everything that comes
to your head the purpose of this is to
free up mental RAM so your mind isn't so
cluttered empty your thoughts onto the
paper and become clear-headed and more
productive step 2 is to prioritize
everything on that list ranked every
task on that list from most urgent to
least urgent step 3 is to cut cut out
any tasks that can wait till tomorrow
put them on another list put them on
another list and forget about that put
them on another list and forget about
the CIM put them on another list and
forget about them completely until
you've finished everything on the main
list step 4 is to chunk and shout out to
improvement pillow for his idea on this
one basically you take all the items on
your main list and break them down into
their most basic parts each of these
parts should take no more than about
half an hour to complete each take make
a youtube video for example I should
break this down into half an hour chunks
because making a YouTube video is a very
long creative process so to see that
task on an average checklist makes me
just look at it and want to avoid it
right script first half right screen
second half record voiceover record
facecam stuff which is what this is cut
the raw footage add the music title the
sound effects miscellaneous render and
upload those all take roughly about half
an hour
those are manageable chunks that I can
really wrap my head around so basically
rinse and repeat this process for every
single thing on your urgent list and
you'll have nice little bite-sized
chunks that you can basically chip away
at because a mountain has climbed one
step at a time
that was make your checklist like this
every day and you'll be tearing through
tasks like the tank that tore through
mr. Bean's car in that really really sad
mr. bean episode that one time
if you liked this video be sure to
subscribe my channel is just starting
off so it really does help to see that
I've gotten a new subscriber a new
couple of subscribers it shows me that
people actually like the videos and want
to see me make more also commenting
really helps as well if you have any
suggestions or basically just you know
like the video comment because I'll
probably reply to it even if I don't
like it I'll probably reply to it just
because got to get that fan got a build
community alright catch you in the next
video